[Musique]
bonsoir valenciennes ça va alors je suis
très ému ce soir parce que figurez-vous
je suis né à valenciennes c'est quand
même pas rien de faire intégrer dans sa
ville d'origine
avant même de me présenter je vais vous
proposer qu on se remue un peu parce que
je suis quand même la 9e intervention de
la soirée je pense que vous donnez tous
et je ne suis pas d'accord avec ça parce
que maintenant on va parler du bonheur
donc je vais vous demander déjà de
remuer vous épaule un petit peu
allez on y va on se fait du bien on a
compris que dans la vie il fallait se
donner
voilà je vais vous demander de vous
étirer soit comme ça soit vers vos
jambes en bavent que vous êtes assis
voilà et de tourner la tête pour
soulager les cervicales et pousse dans
kh lexus si vous allez tout de suite
moi je les fais ça m'a fait du bien
quand même
alors bonsoir je l'appellerai de l'ue
perez comme vous l'avez compris
j'ai 37 ans et je vais vous raconter un
petit bout de mon histoire et des gens
que j'ai pu accompagner
donc en fait à l'âge de 30 ans je me
suis retrouvé en avoir marre d'être
heureuse oui oui vous allez bien entendu
marre d'être heureuse enfin l'inde être
heureuse disons comme la société et
comme mes parents tout ce qu'on entend
autour de nous me laver inculqué c'est à
dire que j'étais marié j'avais une
maison un métier qui me plaisait bien
et à côté de ça va ça ne l'empêchait pas
d'être malheureuse et de pleurer en
cachette tous les jours pendant des mois
forcément ça pose question
quand vous avez tous la santé la famille
les amis le travail il ya un problème il
ya une part de vous qui n'est pas
entendue est donc un moment je me suis
posé la bonne question
1 comme on disait le problème ça peut
pas être les autres c'est forcément en
soi et j'ai je me suis rendue compte
qu'elle est toute une partie de moi que
je n'avais jamais exploré parce que ba
ba parce qu'on n'avait jamais appris à
le faire
puis voilà j'ai reçu beaucoup beaucoup
de choses dans mon éducation dans ma vie
mais pas ça et j'ai commencé à me
plonger dans cet univers que me
faudrait-il pour être heureuse
sauf que là le problème vous voyez c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a défini la mettre
dans térieur au réveil la soif de l'âme
on a envie de tout savoir tout connaître
je suis passé par toutes les phases
j'ai tout tester toutes les techniques
mais au final c'est pas la technique qui
importe c'est kate qui me faisait vibrer
il fallait déjà que je sache qui j'étais
et je m'accepte en tant que personne
donc c'est quand même une grosse
révolution intérieure
a la base je suis de formation
orthophoniste
depuis tout petit bon j'avais dit à mes
parents je serai ou caissières ou
madonna
mon père m'a dit soit mcdonald's gagnent
plus d'argent
bon au final j'étais orthophoniste parce
que j'avais cette fibre en moi de
vouloir aider les gens et donc du coup
je sais ça pendant pas mal d'années je
suis épanoui et ça ne va pas et je me
dis tiens à côté j'avais fait des
formations pour la gestion du stress
pour mes patients pour qu'ils sentent
mieux aussi pendant qu'on travaillé et
je me dis tiens je pourrais peut-être
faire quelque chose là dedans on va voir
les signes de la vie et effectivement
j'ai eu des signes on est venu me voir
pour ça alors que je faisais pas
spécialement de pub au début et là ça a
été une belle aventure tellement belle
est tellement riche que je ne pourrai
pas tout raconter la plupart des gens me
disent oui mais toi aurélie dans la vie
tu as de la chance ils confondent chance
et opportunités c'est à dire que lui et
une opportunité je la saisis d'ailleurs
je suis ici ce soir par un plus grand
des hasards une belle opportunité lien
mais je suis aussi ici parce que j'aime
parler avec les gens et que forcément il
ya un échange
donc on se on se nourrit les uns les
autres
on partage nos valeurs et on monte des
projets qui sont dans ces valeurs ça
c'était la première chose parce que
c'est trop facile de dire tu as de la
chance
on ne sait pas le nombre d'heures de
travail qu'il ya derrière parce que sa
demande en sacrifice personnel et c'est
donc non c'est pas si facile que ça donc
l'idéalisation du bonheur pourquoi ce
titre dont j'ai après je vous montrais
des juste quelques petites photos c'est
pour dire que souvent on veut tout tout
de suite j'ai entendu ce soir beaucoup
parlé de sa demande de la persévérance
ça demande des efforts oui c'est vrai
puis parce que les plus belles choses
qui se construisent demande du temps
donc j'ai envie de vous dire vous avez
un projet ne le lâchez pas vous avez
votre objectif en ligne de mire mais là
maintenant là tout de suite
quelle première marche vous devez
franchir ce que vous êtes posé la
question
la première marche n'est pas obligé
d'être difficile parce que bon quand on
regarde au bout c'est un peu compliqué
on joue là il faut que je fasse tout ça
la première manche serait déjà de se
faire du bien est ce que vous faites du
bien est ce que tous les matins vous
arrivez à vous lever le matin avec le
sourire même quand il ya des problèmes
parce que c'est ça être heureux c'est
pas avoir une vie parfaite personne ne
l'a on a tous eu des proches qui nous
ont quittés des soucis de santé les
problèmes de travaillant avec des chats
fille racing bien sûr c'est toujours de
la faute des chefs aussi n'est au final
qu'est ce que le bonheur si ce n'est les
détails de la vie si ce n'est de
profiter de ce qu'on vit denis être trop
en avant ni trop dans le passé la
nostalgie mais d'être dans le moment
présent
comme ce soir par exemple vous pincez
une merveilleuse soirée en notre
compagnie et ça sent donc un de mes
projets bonheur c'était justement
l'année dernière j'avais je me suis dit
oh j'en ai marre tout est morose en
france j'étais dans ma base je me
permets aussi un pack bien parfois de
pleurer et de râler de bouder donc
j'étais dans ma faim dans ma phase olala
en france y'a rien qui bouge donc je
suis parti faire une étude du bonheur à
l'étranger bien sûr sans sponsor avec
juste un billet aller et ma valise de 20
kg nous quand je dis ça les gens se
disent oh bah oui
mais après tu allais revenir alors non
je le but c'était pourquoi pas
s'installer à l'étranger j'avais pas
prévu de revenir et en + 20 kg pourquoi
parce que je me suis dit si je reviens
ce je sais que j'ai mon appart mes
affaires à la moindre difficulté je vais
rentrer donc j'avais tout donné à des
associations et l'ont vraiment j'avais
que ma valise de 20 kg et quand je suis
revenu presque un an après en france
avec juste ma valise de 20 kg plus
d'économies bien sûr plus de travail
aussi il a fallu tout recommencer c'est
pour ça quand les gens disent tu as de
la chance je préfère me dire que je me
donnais moyens le bonheur c'est exigeant
mais c'est une belle exigence
alors voilà ça donne ça petite séance
photo avant de partir pour le voyage
heureuse un chanson de pharrell williams
ana pis je vais découvrir plein de
personnes plein de choses le monde
m'attend ça a été vraiment quand même 1
et première étape new york
pourquoi new york parce que la ville de
tous les possibles ce n'est pas une
légende
vous arrivez à new york vous parler avec
des gens leur d'après vous avez un
rendez vous je les tester je suis parti
sans contact avec juste une annonce sur
linkedin
et voilà et donc justement jarrige parle
avec des gens j interview un jeune
français qui est partie s'expatrier
parce que le but c'était aussi de savoir
pourquoi les gens s'expatrient pourquoi
il chercher leur bonheur ailleurs que
dans leur pays d'origine et est en fait
je me dis ah bah tiens en même temps je
reprends mes études de la cornée le tec
il ya l'ouverture tu veux venir abbaoui
allons-y et là je me retrouve dans les
bureaux de google new york deuxième jour
souhaitait pas mal ça s'annonçait bien
donc on a pas c'est vraiment un très
très bon moment il faut savoir aussi
quand même que les américains ne sont
pas très fidèle c'est à dire comment je
pourrais si vous prenez votre chance sur
la seconde même tout va bien si vous
donne la carte en dix ans à peine moins
demain il se rappellera jamais de vous
et vous allez appeler et ce ne sera pas
possible
donc il faut vraiment saisir votre
chance sur le moment c'est une belle
école d'ailleurs
j'ai rencontré des expatriés malheureux
quitter la france vraiment parce que
c'est leur pays c'est leur culture et à
leur famille leurs amis mais tellement
épanouie d'être dans des pays où on leur
donne l opportunité on leur faisait
confiance où il pouvait arriver par
exemple à 22 ans et on leur confie une
vraie mission avec des responsabilités
où il pouvait arriver avec des
apparences physiques complètement hors
norme et ça ne dérangeait personne ou
aller un entretien en californie en
costard cravate est très mal vu il vaut
mieux arriver en jean tee shirt le pays
de facebook un nom voilà je m'en vais je
passe de new york à un moment magnifique
avec des conférences des rencontres et
deuxième étape san francisco et là c'est
la révélation de mon bonheur pourquoi je
ne sais pas je ne saurais pas vous
l'expliquer je ne sais pas si je devrais
tenter de l'expliquer j'étais juste
heureuse c'est à dire que l'énergie de
la ville
c'est une très jolie ville des gens qui
viennent vous parler spontanément sans
aucun a priori d'aucune sorte
les personnes ce qui vous donne vos
chances vous parlez pareil une fois je
parle à quelqu'un qui me dit mais écoute
moi je connais un cadre chez linkedin tu
m'en parlent toujours en disant que
c'est un réseau quitte à port louis
tu veux le rencontrer bah oui quelques
jours après mais voici une revue rôle du
cnu est avec vous savez la fin de la
visite sur le toit terrasse où on va
tout la baie de san francisco
et là on dit la vie est quand même folle
je ne sais pas où je vais dormir ce soir
je ne sais pas si je vais pouvoir manger
demain mais pour le moment je vais
passer un bon moment
profitons-en donc voilà le fameux golden
gate j'espère le revoir
je vous avoue les fameuses rue qui monte
alors ça la petite année au teint hâlé
un rendez-vous à san francisco à pied
très mauvaise idée
forcément j'avais pas les moyens de
prendre les transports en commun qui
sont très chers et ils vous disent par
exemple 5 minutes 10 minutes pour y
aller ce qu'ils ne disent pas c'est que
ça c'est ça que vous arrivez avec à
votre rendez-vous tout transpirant
ressemblait à rien et vous n'avez pas
une minute
peut-être que vous vous n'avez pas
l'habitude de marcher dans les rues
comme ça très rigolo
voyez quand même moi et pour vous
montrer un peu le dénivelé et après
belle aventure aussi ça aussi c'est le
fruit du hasard
une amie qui me dit bon écoute on va
couvrir les invictus games tu connais
non pas du tout c'est une compétition
internationale créée par le prince harry
pour permettre aux militaires qui ont
été blessés sur le terrain guerre au
pape en guerre ou pas en guerre de se
reconstruire à travers le sport par le
soutien aussi leur famille leurs amis et
concept génial c'était une création
magazine le seul magazine qui traitait
du sport militaire pour justement lui
faire une place dans le monde allez on y
va
salle où je me suis retrouvé là sur la
photo je fais ma ligne avec mon ayem
disney world 2 oui c'est à orlando
alors j'ai pas pu faire d'attraction
toujours la question qu'on me pose non
je n'ai pas pu mais on a passé une
semaine absolument magnifique avec des
sportifs avec donc le prince harry
forcément qui étaient avec nous ce qui
était franchement il est bluffant c'est
juste incroyable la proximité qu'il a
avec les gens le bonheur qu'ils
communiquent aux gens c'est juste
incroyable
et donc nous fameux sportifs qui ont
tout donné pendant une semaine où le
principe est vraiment de se dire ok on
en compétition mais on est surtout là
pour dire qu'on peut continuer notre vie
on n'a plus la santé physique
on n'a plus forcément la même place dans
la société c'est dur non on continue et
on a des messages de paix aussi souvent
les gens disant oui mais moi les
militaires de la guerre ça m'intéresse
pas non ces gens là et vous expliquent
bien qu'ils sont là pour défendre leur
pays en cas de problème mais que dans
leur for intérieur
ce qu'ils veulent c'est la paix ils sont
jamais autant heureux que quand tout se
passe bien vous voyez
et ce n'était des rencontres incroyables
je me rappelle d'un jordanien
donc on donnait des exemplaires du
magazine qui m'a demandé de lui
dédicacer son magazine non mais attendez
il venait d'être médaille d'or mais non
mais moi je voudrais l'indien ndi non si
tu savais c'est bien la première fois
qu'on donne la parole à des jordaniens
château beau donc voilà et ils étaient
tous entourés de leur famille leurs amis
et c'est ça aussi qui les portait je me
rappelle de quelqu'un qui m'a dit mais
tu sais si je suis encore vivant à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui c'est ma femme et
mon fils parce que moi je peux plus
défendre mon pays j'ai plus la forme
physique pour avoir un poste je suis
revenu complètement traumatisés de ce
qui m'est arrivé c'est eux qui me donne
envie de me lever et de vivre et donc
bien sûr toutes ses médailles parce
qu'il en a gagné beaucoup
il les a dédiée à sa famille
ensuite c'était le mexique non le
mexique n'est pas qu'un pays de cactus
je voulais vous me dire c'est pas parce
que j'ai vu un gros chat dans un cactus
qui a que ça ce n'est pas non plus que
le pays des barbapapas rose violet et
bleu pas si vous les connaissiez moi je
les ai découvertes là bas c'est aussi un
pays plein de contrastes
c'est à dire que vous avez je suis allée
alexis quotidien dans la dans la
capitale vous avez une ville incroyable
qui est dans une cuvette entourée de
montagnes avec la nappe de pollution au
dessus complètement surpeuplées avec des
problèmes de réserves d'eau forcément et
faut savoir aussi que là bas ils boivent
plus de coca que d'eau tout simplement
parce que le coca coûte moins cher
qu'une bouteille d'eau donc gros
problèmes de santé d'hydratation etc
et en plus les usines coquins qui sont
installés chez eux leur prenne toute
l'eau des nappes phréatiques parce que
si ma mémoire est bonne il faut 5 litres
d'eau pour faire un litre de coca
donc j'espère que je vous ai bien tous
culpabiliser ce soir pour le coquin et
que vous allez arrêter de torture et les
mexicains ces groupes est donc là
c'était incroyable parce que c'est des
gens qui bat ils sont quand même dans un
niveau de vie ou ne s'est pas évident et
en fait il vous accueille les bras
ouverts
ils sont toujours souriant un petit
détail c'est vrai le mexique est quand
même bien pollué par la corruption
donc c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir des
aventures qui sont pas très agréables à
vie mais globalement ça a été un accueil
juste incroyable dans des familles
qu'ils ne connaissaient même pas et
juste sur le contact du contact mois
cueillie chez eux et donc le pays des
cultures le mexique n'a jamais oublié sa
culture en ciel là vous voyez par
exemple une pyramide aztèque
mais par contre ils font des additions
c'est à dire que tout ce qui tout ce qui
a de bien dont les nouvelles
civilisations qui sont venus chez eux
quand ils ont été évangélisé à un moment
ils prennent tout ce qui leur correspond
et le reste et laisse de côté ça ça
pourrait être un exemple pour votre vie
et si vous prenez tout ce qui vous
correspondez et que vous arrêtiez de
prendre ce qui ne vous correspond pas ça
vous allégerait déjà et après direction
le pérou alors là le pérou c'était moins
sympa pour moi parce que en fait là
j'avais vraiment plus plus plus d'argent
j'avais fait au secours papa maman parce
que là ça va pas et j'ai de la chance
d'avoir une famille d'ailleurs et je me
retrouve en plus à lima qu'on appelle du
mal à grease je ne savais pas 90% du
temps il fait gris alors pour le moral
vous savez un petit peu les effets du
temps sur le moral on habite dans le
nord tous nos conseils
et ce n'était pas facile parce qu'en
plus cela je n'ai pas vraiment pu
approcher des locaux il y avait vraiment
une grosse barrière il ya une telle
différence de si vous voulez il voit un
européen il pense argent quoi donc j'ai
pas pu avoir de contact authentique
comme je le voulais sauf dans la
deuxième partie à cusco du côté les
montagnes donc là c'était le la petite
plage de les mains juste pour le plaisir
ou là vraiment on est dans la vie
authentique donc là j'ai pu rencontrer
des gens notamment une jeune fille de 20
ans avec qui on parle un petit peu de
tout alors il a voulu m'emmener chez les
chats mâles et tout jeter chouette et
elle me dit on parlait de pauvreté à un
moment et là par contre elles se ferment
complètement et elle me dit oh toi la
française n'a pas le droit de parler de
pauvreté
oups qu'est ce que j'ai dit parce que
c'est ça aussi le problème quand on va
dans d'autres cultures c'est parfois on
fait d un père sans s'en rendre compte
et elle me dit mais attends mais même
les plus pauvres de chez toi ils sont
plus riches que nous de oui ce n'est pas
vrai c'est pas faux asie vous vous avez
des aides vous avez encore des des
foyers qui vont accueillir l moi j'ai
bossé pour des associations je t'assure
la pauvreté ici c'est quand même autre
chose
donc tu ne peux pas utiliser ce mot de
corps je respecte donc après lima et
cuzco
je fais enfin un trekking pour moi
c'était le seul moment où j'ai pris pour
moi où je suis parti en montagne
toujours avec cette zone est où là en
haut de la montagne
je me suis sentie heureuse juste en
communion avec la nature juste ne penser
à rien juste me dire bah oui ok faut que
je rentre en france
oui j'ai conscience que je suis
complètement déconnecté complètement
plus en phase je ne sais pas ce que je
vais faire ça peut faire peur ça peut
être vertigineux donc ça peut faire
comment la montagne se dire que tout est
possible et que pourquoi pas
à 37 ans ça fait déjà deux fois je
redémarre à zéro pourquoi pas une
troisième
où est le problème qu'est ce que voulez
vous dire c'est que j'ai co j'ai
rencontré des gens aussi quand je suis
parti dans tout ce qui était le coaching
émotionnelle la santé le bonheur au
travail
j'ai accompagné des gens qui souvent
trompée de problématique
c'est à dire par exemple je me rappelle
d'une dame qui me disait ça fait 15 ans
que je travaille ma confiance en moi et
ça n'avance pas et on parle on creuse et
son problème c'était pas la confiance en
elle c'est elle estime d'elle-même pour
vous dans la salle vous sentez peut-être
pas la différence et non je ne vous
donnerai pas la réponse ce soir
parce que le but c'est d'éveiller les
consciences manque à vous de chercher et
vous verrez que si on se trompe
d'objectif dans la vie on ne peut pas
avancer
quinze ans qu'elle travaille sur un
objectif qui n'est pas sa problématique
on a recadré ont institué à la sortie du
bureau en disant enfin je vais avancer
c'était pas résolu non attention ça
demande du travail
mais enfin elle avait un petit bout
d'idées un petit bout du chemin qui se
dévoilait face à elle surtout dites vous
une chose ce qui nous fait peur c'est
l'inconnu alors que ça devrait nous
enthousiasmer pour ce soir on va
terminer avec juste un petit exercice je
voulais justement vous repartiez avec un
exemple de ce qui pourrait vous était
dans la vie quotidienne et je vais
reprendre l'exemple de la respiration
car c'est la première chose qu'on fait
quand on est et quand on earth on rend
notre dernier souffle
c'est notre dernier acte ça veut bien
dire que sans respiration pas d'huile
pailletée d'aix
donc nous allons travailler ça il ya un
exercice qui s'appelle la cohérence
cardiaque
les scientifiques ont calculé le rythme
parfait idéal pour calmer vos battements
de coeur et donc avec pour conséquence
de vous apaiser tout simplement
et bien souvent pour prendre les bonnes
décisions la première étape c'est déjà
d'avoir un mental clair pas se
précipiter dans la peur les craintes et
c'est donc l'exercice est simple on vous
a fait un petit un petit montage vous
voyez le ronge au delà au milieu pas le
rouge et or aujourd'hui il va bouger
de haut en bas quand il monte vous
inspirez amplement par le nez vous
gonfler le ventre quand ils descendent
vous soufflez par la bouche et vous
rentrez le ventre
vous me fait plaisir faites le au moins
six fois de suite et connectez vous
est-ce que ça fait dans votre corps
c'est parti on y va on inspire et on
souffle
vous pouvez mettre une main sur vos
ventes pour sentir le moment on inspire
un sou
allez encore
accrochez-vous c'est la moitié
c'est la dernière on inspire
et on souffre
ça va déjà mieux nous de petites choses
ont pensé positive en un exercice qui
consiste à répéter une phrase c'est la
plante danser positive celle là elle
marche à chaque fois je vous la
recommande tous les matins devant le
miroir je suis unique
je suis magnifique il n'y a que moi
comme moi et je vous assure vous êtes
unique vous êtes magnifique
il n'ya que vous comme vous vous voulez
que le monde change
commencez déjà par vous même soyez le
changement que vous voulez voir dans le
monde comme disait gandhi merci pour
votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]